togehter up boys let's get this over six  little recon yourself at you without  went to the west darling copy  if you'll bring it down  [Music]  to x-rays down first secure to the  second floor  [Music]  Louis Aquila understand prophecy taking  the third for long  suck it up  [Applause]  locked try a camera  no get down get down all teams turn are  secured commence sse3 boss Roger sauce  the place sergeant goodbye [ __ ] now  she was going for bloody debt and they  are good job we dropped it in we made  the right call sir about your house  we've got a location on her wolf the  Attic of the our khatallah townhouse was  a gold mine looks like we found the wolf